Robbie Knievel Daredevil and Son of
stuntman Evil Knievel has died he was 60
years old
[Music]
according to TMZ Robbie spent his final
days in hospice care after a battle with
pancreatic cancer and died on Friday
with his daughters by his side
[Music]
Robbie also known as Captain Robbie
Knievel followed in his dad's footsteps
from a young age jumping his bike at
only four years old and performing at
evil show at Madison Square Garden when
he was eight he would sit in the
ambulance and tell me and my brother
look at me you know he'd be busted up
I'd never want you to do this and my
older brother chose a smart profession
which wasn't jumping and I chose jumping
because I don't know I had the eye of
the tiger it's my passion I've been
doing it for 34 years Robbie went on to
perform over 350 jumps in his career 20
of which said World Records
foreign
[Applause]
in 1989 he jumped The Fountains at
Caesar's Palace in Las Vegas a feat his
dad previously tried and failed I was
probably doing
75 when I left the end of the ramp let's
let's look at the monitor here you can
see it some of his most memorable stunts
include the 30 limousines jump the Grand
Canyon jump and the USS Intrepid jump
his final stunt was in 2011 when he
jumped 150 feet above tractor-trailer
trucks at the Spotlight 29 Casino in
Coachella California
foreign
Robbie also starred in the short-lived
show Knievel's Wild Ride giving fans a
look behind the scenes of his wild
stunts when I'm not breaking record I'm
just breaking bones